and so maybe talk a little bit about
just like at what point did you realize
like I'm actually conducting business
here right I'm actually an entrepreneur
it's not just me with like a bunch of
side hustles like that there's a
structure to this and I can do this in
any industry right whether it's DJing
whether it's with shoes whether it's
with jewelry like it's the same thing
over and over again just in different
industries and creating value so what
happened was I never worked in anything
I didn't actually have an interest in
people have a hard time becoming
successful in one career like you said
right
I had a successful I was successful in
three careers okay and one of those
careers being to side careers you know
um this how it goes
I never had a wealth manager or a CPA to
advise me on how to incorporate myself
and do things like that I was like oh my
god [ __ ] somebody tell me this you
know a long time ago like I just [ __ ]
off you know like one it was saving me
enormous amount of money on taxes and
whatever things like that but um from
music early on I saw where I missed
opportunities to make money I could have
sold mixtapes here boom but if I sold
5000 mixtapes well it cost me nothing
but my labor and some basic cost boom
okay there's also the cost to buy
cassettes that news of mixtape right now
that's like some [ __ ] we're talking
about real mix tapes that were like you
know like they were blended through and
there was this and that and people
elevated it and all of a sudden they
call it mixtape it's part of a record
label it's like not a mixtape it's like
songs is also it was just different so
anyway it's going on I realized that
missed opportunities I had as a record
executive when I became a solo DJ I
started to understand alright how
important it is to market myself so if
you remember that movie American Pie is
that what's called I forgot the dude's
name was but he told that one chick
natasha Lyonne I think to tell everybody
he had a really big penis or something
Ryan it was like a boom it was like a
rumor went around and like in a way I
was telling people oh you know man yeah
you know I'm getting paid like five six
dollars a night 500 was definitely was
mark ronson nobody was getting paid that
much in a nightclub back then in the 90s
and like I was telling people yeah man
you know his crazy man wanted Paris next
week to go DJ this this and this and I
was making up these stories but I was
doing it because I had no other way to
promote myself and people were like you
know what and it was like it's Instagram
like Oh where's the pictures at there's
no [ __ ] cameras back there like you
they barely had the disposable camera
back there but no one had no one really
carried you you had like guys who had no
professional photo but it was like no it
wasn't that common to have to take
pictures of your other me sometimes yeah
but me it just was I know I'm Asian
people like all the cameras that was a
big joke back in the 80s you know 90s
and 70s you know Japanese people always
have cameras right well it was I didn't
have work so I started marketing and I
developed this folklore of Ben Butler
being bigger than he was it landed me a
job in Vegas at the Hard Rock Hotel
Casino I am getting a billboard there
that start you know start doing and I
started taking out ads in newspapers the
LA Weekly and small ads like a boom you
know men bars doing missus people and be
a dragonfly here and I started to
realize that was good then the sneaker
thing was part of my DJ because I was
DJing I was selling weed the weed money
those cash was going into sneakers the
sneakers when they got sold or whatever
they did I've watched the cash at that
point they weren't checking [ __ ] like
that back in the day
eBay wasn't even [ __ ] charging your
feet people in charge of things now
people I was making sure the taxes are
done you know I mean like they're
hitting you they're recording everything
it wasn't like that back then
you know even on eBay eBay had a feature
where you were able to look let's say
for instance I'm like I want to see what
pop is buying today oh [ __ ] pom-pom KY
jelly he bought two pairs of Nikes
specific things I could see everything
you bought I could see the things we
even watching it was crazy a super you
know like invasive of your privacy but I
was able to like you know just I
understood like alright I got this
little thing here okay let's make some
t-shirts and I'm gonna say they're
limited edition I only made 100 nobody
[ __ ] knew I made 500 whatever it was
and we did it and they sold out and so
that was another hustle
and then I created a crew airmax crew
this is the sneaker called the aromatics
but then there's the term Mac which is
sort of like a pimp mi CK so I called
ourselves to air max crew so we were
like the Nike pit crew right it was me
this guy named DJ homicide who was very
famous he was a group called Sugar Ray
an enormous rock band pop band and then
DJ and rest in peace who was my boy and
we had an honorary member who no one
even knows is his name is domain II he
own flight club he started flying but
this time was called vintage chicks you
know he sold his company for 60 million
dollars it's a lot of money so we had
this crew I was doing appearances I was
able to market myself without a manager
I had an email address that was my
acting manager no one ever met this
person he's like Charlie from [ __ ]
Charlie's Angels right and I was just
able to to to you know keep elevating
myself but as basketball happened I told
you I wish I had another year was out of
the year this where I'm at you know I
wasn't a rapper or certain things were
like you know after you turn 30 you're
like washed up and want to hear your
music getting more like oh yeah not
talking about drugs and guns anymore and
blah blah it's harder as you get older
to be a rapper to stay credible stay
relevant so you know I never looked at
it the entrepreneur side until I sold my
collection and I realized totally [ __ ] I
couldn't do this a long time ago and not
have a sell an entire bulk I could have
did this in a different way but I
understood at that point anything I'm
passionate about I'm going to find a way
to make money so when I started the
jewelry business even that I said we got
to create a separate name we have
friends certainly on MySpace to promote
it and then we have the traditional
stuff we can put fliers out and do
certain things or whatever I can start
marking and putting on celebrities of
course that's the best potion whatever
and I started realizing okay we're big
we got so big that I haven't combed my
company which stands for internally
flawless and company internally flawless
is technically the best diamond you
could possibly get in the world
our company was really called I see
fresh ink Oh honest Cee and we were
using the IC logo like its icy eyes
it's all melted with ice and everything
and then we had fresh in a engravers
farm sector for cash money font and I
have them together and putting this out
there
I see the the slushee corporation sees
that when you google I see we were
coming up in the top five they want to
own the top 20 on Google so they send a
cease and desist to us because they're
saying that we're confusing people
because we're talking about ice and
stuff like well ice is a [ __ ] is a
slang for diamonds you know the mean
slang for jewelry and they're like okay
we don't care that happens boom we have
to restructure and at that point I said
i man look you want to get big okay
Tiffany and coda to sell t-shirts they
don't need to they have the turquoise
box that's their marketing thing right
what do we have
alright we need to go out here and
market this [ __ ] so we're making plastic
pieces I started making t-shirts unless
that became I was making enough side
[ __ ] that wasn't jewelry well
technically the plastic things were
t-shirts that was taking care of our
entire payroll that hustle so everything
else dollars has cream on the top you
know I'm saying it's [ __ ] icing
literally pun intended right so I um I
started to realize hey man you know I
think all this dope but what about Ben
baller the brand so I just started to
market myself after Oh 8 and you know it
just every you know five years or so
leave unless I led what I'm doing